They put one of his own fans, another fan of his, they put her
name and address on the letter and he published it because he's
a
>> Why Why is this in your head? Why you Why is your head
dominated by by this fantasy of yours? Hmm,
very concerning.
All right, so where do we start with the Chibi Reviews stuff?
Let's pick up where we left off. Uh why not? With the Shamu clip,
the Shamu jokes, the Shamu memes. All right, we smoking on >> on
Eddie. We remember the Chibi Reviews stuff, the the chair,
Eddie getting dug up, all of this [__]
We smoking on >> on Eddie. Slide for Eddie. Thousands of
people upon thousands of people retweeting this and cheering
it on in the quotes and in the comments. Desecrating a grave.
We smoking on Eddie. Slide for Eddie. >> Comparing me to
Hitler, comparing me to Stalin, you have called me a You have
called me a Nazi, you have called me a pedo, you have called
me a These people want me to die. Slide for Eddie. That's That's
what they want. We smoking on Eddie. After this all happened
with Chibi Reviews, Chibi Reviews started getting really mad
at the Kiwi Farms, okay? She was getting big mad at Kiwi Farms
and basically what I saw or what what I saw mostly was people
from outside of Kiwi Farms were laughing about posts that were
kind of threatening Chibi Reviews. Now, I would say
almost certainly from anonymous platforms where there's almost
no reason to believe that these reviews or sorry, these um not
reviews, that these threats had any reliability to them, that
they were real.
This is what, April 24th? April 24th, 25th, okay? This is null.
Every time I make fun of some pet cause like Pragmatist or Saba's
debut, they want to tell me, "Whoa!" I get a wave of mentally
ill stunted freaks modding at but the Kiwi Farms. They're calling
this post a little assassination plot. That's why they're mad.
So, this is Null talking about Chibi Reviews, okay?
Apparently, Chibi Reviews very upset, says this is like a legitimate
attack on If anyone goes to his house and puts soyjaks on his
door or through his letterbox, I will literally pay you for gas
money up to 200 USD if you post your Monero wallet.
That's tempting cuz I'm like 40 minutes
This guy says. And Chibi Reviews, well, I understand this is
like scary.
These are anonymous accounts. There's like not really like
Okay, they're not threatening violence. I would also say these
people need to understand that if they got shot, I don't think
they'd be able to defend
Okay? But Chibi Reviews did maybe the worst thing you can do
in this situation, which was to blow it up, blow it out of proportion,
overreact repeatedly
so that everybody becomes focused on it. Yes, that is a post
from 4chan and they're laughing about it on Kiwi Farms,
Post from 4chan that they're laughing about on KF.
It's I get why
he's upset, but focusing it on this stuff and blowing it up on
Oh, maybe it's soyjak.party. I don't know. It's some It's some
two sham board, some
some some anonymous message board, okay? Doesn't really matter
which one.
Regardless, he blows it up on Twitter for no reason. Kiwi Farms
owner, Josh, has people right now on his platform trying to fund
an assassination attempt on me less than 20 minutes ago. Here's
an archive proving this is real since he's trying to cover it
up. Namekian George Floyd says,
Do we start a GoFundMe for the R Ns?
He's talking about the Boruto fans. Josh going to pay a pack
of fair old Ns to come to his house and assault him and then
take a [__] all over his We start a GoFundMe for
these R Ns. You guys can fill it in. I'm trying to be cool, okay?
I want to give those fine gentlemen what they're worth. So, these
are memes.
Dargon's wife's son says, "Can we start a GoFundMe?" Oh, sorry.
"We're We're only going to need $200 to get the our our N-words
to his house.
Don't worry, we made it the mass. I love the bones of his dead
brother.
So, these people are like memeing. And I get why it's frustrating.
You shouldn't blow it up, okay?
He makes that post.
People I think mostly agree with him in his replies, right? I
think if I I think finding Josh is dude, this is so stupid. Okay.
Next week, we're going to go through a couple of these cuz Shirby
Reviews spent the entire night very upset. Talk about calling
the FBI and
So, Kiwi Farms currently has people trying to get me assassinated.
This is a recent post on your site 5 minutes ago. This is not
on Kiwi Farms. Here's the archive since you're deleting comments
trying to hide his trying to hide this. I've got 200 Canadian
dollars in a mostly unused Netflix subscription for anyone who
is willing to Shirby Reviews in real life, which we disavow.
Now, uh he goes have the archive here, and that did happen.
But again, this is like totally banned on the platform, right?
Like it is a free speech platform. It is a platform where anybody
can sign up and post something, but this behavior is banned.
This person would be banned
Which I I understand why it's frustrating that's happening at
all. Also clear joke? I would say also a clear joke. I understand
why people don't want to take it as a joke when it's their safety
that's supposedly like that that seems to be at risk, right?
You don't want to take it as a joke, but this person would get
automatically banned. It's just totally against the rules to
ever get involved like that off platform. So, Shirby Reviews
then posts, what is
First off, apologies to my community. This is on the 25th again.
First off, apologies to my community for the last few days. The
tremendous support is beautiful. A lot has been going on behind
the scenes. I can't elaborate any further. From now on, I'll
go radio silent and watch what happens next. It is out of my
hands now. So, he was talking about calling the FBI and that
was all
That was all over the place. This is right after that, right?
Right after we covered that yesterday or 2 days ago, 3 days ago,
that he's calling the FBI, that people the cops are at his house.
I literally don't remember what he called the police about. But,
then we get to the next day. Your boy রিভিউস decides to post
this. Got a threat to my life in the mail. Here we find that
others are encouraging this. People telling me to to not take
it serious or it's just jokes. Explain this [__]
So, he was um he was sent this in the
And what happened here, what he didn't catch, is that this is
an address. So, just in the same way that this is his name and
then it would be his address, this is another name and address.
This name and address does not belong to the person who sent
him the mail. Obviously, if somebody's going to harass you in
real life like this, they're not going to put their name and
address on the letter. In fact, they put one of his own fans,
fan of his, they put her name and address on the letter. And
he published it because he's a
total [__]
Yeah, I'm not joking. That's what he did. They put somebody else's
address on here, their name and address, and he posted it cuz
he's a idiot. I got another post of the letter. It's like it's
like a I mean, the letter is bad, I guess. You [__]
up bad. You [__] up blinding yourself with Vondra
Von Dragon, Pedro Garcia, and Mr. Anime 343, all of which who
were ex- which who were exposed for being You [__]
up having Cee Sem on DeviantArt. You [__] up trying
to take down my first video on you. You [__] up in
playing a part in suspending my @ Zeno Conoske account. I'll
get it back, lol. You [__] up scamming your fanbase,
and you [__] up making an enemy out of me. Now, I'm
going to make sure I strip everything away from you. I took your
Twitter down once before, so doing it again isn't going to be
hard. But, since you try want to try to to deep depth forward,
I assume that's
people who expose you, I'm aiming for your YouTube as well. You're
You deserve all of this, Jacob. Shouldn't have made an enemy
out of me. It's like schizo.
Schizo. Like this is somebody who's who's like
I think trying to cosplay a schizo, probably also some level
schizo themselves. But they're like cos playing extra schizo
to freak him out to get him to publish it cuz they just want
that address published to humiliate him.
This takes us to
the first Harmful Opinions video. Thank god for Harmful Opinions
and his fantastic
6-15
minute videos. They are so good. Love me some Harmful Opinions
content, all right? Some have called him the gay riddler. I don't
call him that. He's he's just a good guy. He's just a good guy
overall. >> specifically
about a very basic ethical concept. Let's say you think it's
justified and important. Fine, whatever. There are several scenarios.
But then, you must either go all the way, fully confirm the docs,
and make your post unambiguous, or stop. Don't do it. If you
don't understand why, this video is for you. And hopefully, I
will also undo some of the damage that Chippy Reviews has already
done. On April 24th, I warned Chippy that his behavior is dangerous,
not only to himself, and
So, this is after he posted that stuff. You should start taking
things seriously instead of playing games. Providing a scapegoat
for the people actually doing it to blame one of the sites is
it's being discussed on is you insanely unwise. Not my business,
of course, but felt compelled to dip in at least once in case
you don't understand.
This is basically Harmful Opinions dipping in and going, "Hey,
you should probably try not to be carefuls." Listen, that doesn't
go well for anybody. If you want to try to be carefuls, many
have attempted it, many have regretted it. Do not do it. It is
a massive mistake to try to be carefuls right now, okay? I suggested
that perhaps the people he's upset aren't speaking out aren't
doing so because they can see that as well. More specifically,
I warned him that he is signaling that he can be used as an attack
vector. The way he responds to things with his flailing means
other people can use him like a one-man Kiwi Farms. They submit
a post to him and he shows it to a massive audience. Worse than
Kiwi Farms really, because with him a large level of exposure
is guaranteed every time. And more than that, whereas a site
like Uh dude, also the intent or or the perception of the people
there, he is basically like literally offering up this name and
going, "This is the person who's causing all of my problems.
Hey everybody who's a fan of me, who follows me and loves me,
this is the person who's causing all of my problems." Like you
are blatantly trying to get something bad to happen to them,
right? >> has rules against organizing and doing things
to the people featured. Chibi Reviews has spent the past several
days encouraging his audience to escalate. Chibi explicitly claims
that this is his advice to his audience. Uh don't throw stones
at people wanting you dead. Nah, if they're going to lowblow
you, you return it back 120%
given the chance. Having rigid pacifism only crumbles into bloodstains
on the dirt. The only victory you achieve is being a coward while
suffering alone. Yes, Chibi explicitly condemned not being violent
in the context of talking about people who want him Yeah, based,
you might think. Hold your horses a second. 10 hours ago, at
the time of recording, Chibi Reviews uploaded a photograph of
a letter he received. He describes it as a threat to his life,
although no such threat is present in the pictures. You'll notice
there are two pictures as well. It's actually the letter twice,
but the second one is a person's name and an address, with his
underneath scribbled out. Now someone who goes by SlyFoxSon retweeted
this post and followed up by saying, "Keep Chibi Reviews in your
thoughts." And they then said something very interesting. That's
me, bruh. SlyFox retweets it again and says, "A reason why I
despise the Kiwi Farms because they literally used my preferred
name to send a death threat against someone I'm following." How
confident are you that this is the
who sent that letter? Me, personally, not very. But this is who
Chibbi has painted a target on the back of, with responses to
him further distributing this information and saying things like
payback is going to be [__] Others I will not show
for obvious reasons have been posting images of the property
and suggesting visiting. Have been posting, for instance, the
LinkedIn of a woman obviously unrelated and telling people that
it's her, simply because she has the same name Chibbi shared
to make a target, as he explained he would do a few days ago
in his statement against non-violence. Even if this fan of his,
Slyfox, is the person who sent the letter, the doxx is not done
clearly enough to prevent collateral to other people who share
details. Instead, he just regurgitated personally identifiable
information he was sent in the mail to a mass audience he's been
encouraging to reject pacifism and retaliate to threatening behavior
in the past few days. This is why you either doxx or you don't.
You don't go half-seas. You don't put out a name and an address.
Maybe it's where the person lives. If it's not, it's worse because
now there's an even bigger pool of people that might get attacked,
especially as someone who's been inciting violence over the past
few
Pretty crazy to say like
>> Like we've already jumped through obviously I think
harmful opinions would have a problem with doxxing people in
general. Maybe not depending on what they're doing. Like if they
are if they're like swatting, I don't if you're swatting and
like causing mass harm, I don't think your identity should be
protected. But again, it all comes down to can you prove that
he do any of this stuff, right? >> Telling people to reject
pacifism and escalate in their retaliation, explicitly stating
this is his advice. This is why, especially if you're someone
like Chibbi who incites and endorses escalating retaliation,
you either doxx or you don't. You either confirm who the person
is, confirm that they're responsible, and share enough that no
one can mistake them for someone else. When you're obviously,
clearly, deliberately trying to paint a target on someone's back,
having said explicitly that you are going to try to hurt these
people, or or don't post anything at all. And you certainly don't
just post a name and address you got in the mail and associate
it with a threatening letter. Having just a few days prior told
people to reject pacifism in their dealings with people who do
such things. >> to go. We're going to go. >> Crazy.
Absolute
madness. Many people are defending it on the basis that it's
not clear that that's that person's address or maybe even anyone's
address at all. Doing some digging suggests that's false, but
additionally, that's worse. Ambiguous doxes put more people in
danger. Precise doxes put one in danger. Now, to be clear, if
he'd nailed the person who sent him that silly letter, my response
would be them. Get owned. But not what's happening here. Even
if it is some deranged follower of his who wants attention. Even
if it is that sly fox person, he hasn't doxxed them well enough.
Especially when you've been posting incitement to violence against
people who do certain behaviors and then attach that information
to that kind of behavior. My understanding is that Shoe0nHead
are about the same age. I think he's 30, 31. Based on his behavior,
I wanted to check if he was just a kid or something. But no,
we're about the same age. I'm 30 He does look like a kid. He
looks like he could be a kid. 31 is crazy for Shoe0nHead reviews.
>> For Shoe0nHead, we are not little girls. We are men.
You don't get a pass to do whatever you want cuz you're scared.
When you were just endangering yourself in your little slap fight
with internet trolls, I tweeted at you to warn you that you're
going to become a danger, but otherwise I was happy to watch.
Now I can see you're an active threat to everyone around you
and potentially
Cut it out. Grow up. Stop acting impulsively. If you think this
is serious, start acting like it. Or if this is what you want
to do now, why not delete your YouTube, delete your Twitter,
sign up to Kiwi Farms instead. You'll be safer doing it there.
There's nothing I or anyone else can really do if you're just
another face in the crowd. Except maybe not. You'd get bullied
there too for being [__] at it. By the way, in case
I have your attention and I'm not just talking to the void, I
sent you a message at the start of the month in Twitter DMs.
No threats. Totally chill if you'd like a break from this kind
of thing, and I'd love to hear your answers. A video addressing
it would be fascinating, I'm sure, and it would be easy content.
Anyway, just a quick one because I felt morally obligated to
put the warning out there. Take it easy, have a good one, and
uh
try not to post any random personally identifying information
that trolls send you in the mail.
It's like really the lowest bar, isn't it? Don't have TO DOX
JUST RANDOM DUDES, I GUESS. I don't know, man. Maybe just don't
dox random people. Maybe don't be a complete
Not very difficult to understand.
Okay, thank you, Harmful Opinions. All right, so this is then
following up the next day after this, okay? He does a big statement.
Important official statement. "Over the last week, I've received
some of the best support I could ever ask for as a person. The
love from the community has been a true blessing that allows
me to wake up each day and smile. Truthfully, without you all,
I would be beyond stressed, but I push through knowing I have
a loving community. Now, I must say this next part with full
seriousness, since I've seen it happen over and over the last
few days. Quite a few friends of mine have been mass reported
or targeted targeted lately by bad actors. Those that have come
to my defense are now being harassed and their family as well.
They've even They even have pictures of kids being spammed in
their comments or DMs labeled as D&B.
[__] balls?
I I That's all I could think was say D&B. That's all I could
think of. What the [__]
I ask all of you out there, please don't put yourself in harm's
way for me. These people are criminals, scumbags, and only seek
to do harm. When you side with me openly, it means they want
you next. They will do everything that they can to tear you down
and frighten you off. I want you all to be aware of that these
people can't be reasoned with. I do appreciate that I do appreciate
those that could do continue to speak up in my defense, but only
do so if you're aware of the risks at hand. If you wish to distance
from me because of this, I will fully accept I will fully accept
it and or fully accept it out of respect, okay? With that, I
will go back to my scheduled hentai manga reading.
Okay. Okay. Dude, I
People make jokes, man. I This guy Somehow this guy fights with
everybody in the internet and he's always the
You know, let let's humor this for a second. ChibiReviews fiance
when he wasn't looking.
This going to be something crazy. I don't know what this was,
but it's going to be something crazy, isn't it? You know, let's
humor this for a second. You realize that he's someone that gets
off on being cheated on, right? Also, I left, which is the opposite
of being a Just admit you're projecting your fetish on to me
because you can't even get a girlfriend to you, lmao. Nowhere
did I call you a in that post, bro. That's actually true.
>> Why Why is this in your head? Why are you Why is your
head dominated by by this fantasy of yours?
Very concerning.
Chibi decides to go right at Josh Moon. So, ChibiReviews going
after Null again the next day,
April 28th, important news. Why is Null talking with minors?
This thread is about the site owner of Kiwi Farms, the same guy
that is labeling me a pedo for fictional content. What are you
hiding, Josh? Please address this.
It should be a It should be a dark but gold show today. Josh
Moon literally caught lying about the 15-year-old
In any case, so this guy's basically trying to say that Josh
Moon had some
some concerning conversations with a
It should be a dark but gold show today. Josh Moon literally
caught lying about the 15-year-old called Clara that he loved
as an 18-year-old.
Josh Moon retcons. She was 15, I was 17, almost 2 years younger.
I think we met when she was 18, contradicts him being 17, almost
2 years younger than me. 18-year-old Josh Moon on the Elban account.
On his Elban account? Eban account? And I am just over 2 years
older than her.
Oh, I see. Never asked her to live with me and I'm just over
2 years older than
Okay, so like two people are basically two years apart getting
in a relationship. Nobody's going to be mad about that. This
is totally insane. I Does Chibi Reviews really think he's cooking
with this?
This two-year apart relationship and you're like, "Oh my god,
he's a I knew he was all along."
Really? Really, bro? Okay. All right.
Go off, I guess.
Okay, there's this guy.
I think Josh responds pretty soon. No, we'll start defending
himself at some point in the very near future, okay?
Okay, this getting really grim. It was revealed that Josh became
romantically interested in a 14-year-old and called CPS on her
family when his affection wasn't returned. Other members called
him out and Stalking says he did the same thing to her.
Alforn Child Protective Services are not baby snatchers. That's
because she told me that he called child services on somebody.
Where does it say he fell in love with this person?
Never asked her to live with me and I'm just over 2 years older
than her. Is this all the same person?
So, basically you got Chibi Reviews trying to call this guy over
and over
No, talks about this. Okay, he responds. Sure thing.
So, why is Josh talking to minors? What are you hiding? Please
address this. Sure thing. When I was a teenager, I spoke with
and was attracted to teenagers. This was documented on an internet
forum 15 to 18 years ago. Now that I am 33, I talk to and am
attracted to adults. You're older than me today, but are attracted
to children. See the
Chibi responds. Heard it here first, folks. Josh admits that
he was talking with a child that was 14 to 15 years old while
he was a legal adult at age 18. He also Well, no. Just over 2
years older, that's not mathematically possible. He would have
been younger, like 16.
He means 17 when she was 14. Okay, he also forgot to mention
that this post on Kiwi Farms talking about kids, too, proving
they had images of children on hand that needed to be censored.
I know they're posting it on Facebook and We have to operate
under different rules than the rest of the world. 15 to 8 and
18-year-old 15-year-old at 18 years old, are you a [__]
Lol. One's a kid and one's a legal adult. You'll be arrested
and labeled a criminal. Look up the laws, bozo. That's very possible.
You could be arrested and labeled a criminal.
Sorry, there's going to be more responses here between the two.
Apologies to my community for blowing up everyone's feed. This
is the last post on this for a while now.
Please do forgive me. Null saying they stopped tolerating this
effectively admitting that they were fine with it before. In
addition to allowing the hosting of a slash file board, this
raises some serious concerns. Here's the archive for proof. Cory
Barnhill is a I've had one public conversation with. Whatever
you're the you're implying is your own imagination.
I can't even figure out what you're saying because I'm pretty
sure you're not able to read or write. I stopped tolerating lolicons
after witnessing lolicon posters in 9chan spam Csam to protest
admin decisions. This was years after I talked to the on the
kill stream. Also have no idea why you think I'm afraid of him.
I told his company to eat [__] after they legally
threatened me and tried to censor this thread. No idea who you
are or what you're up to, but you need to lurk more because you're
totally misinformed.
Well, I mean, it's a free speech website, so obviously they they
have some tolerance for stuff they find disgusting but legal,
I'm guessing.
In 2020 I briefly hosted 9chan. My global rules were limited
to user boards not outside of in boards like B or V.
Protested by spamming the site with day and night until I closed
it. That's why I know you're Jake, the tad bee.
Here's my reply you're hiding to by re-posting this. I ain't
hiding anything, lol. You straight-up admitted you talked to
kids and had romantic feelings for them. Dude, this guy is actually
losing it.
This is This is really crazy, this whole
This This is just wild to me. Like when you're trying to do all
this stuff, you're trying to have all these fights with Josh
Moon directly.
Cuz as much as as much as they hate Josh Moon sometimes on Kiwi
Farms, they will defend him if they have to, right? They will
eventually defend this guy.
They don't want to. They want to make fun of him.
But they will eventually come out and say, "Hey,
that's that's my
tolerating admin, okay? That's my guy. What the hell?